this next question says how would the
academic community react to uaps being
real if they were revealed to be i think
that they would have an initial
disbelief and then arrogance that uaps
are obviously quote unquote real
and
they would lack any
reference to their previously
derogatory attitude and have no
remorseful or little remorseful
recognition
for
those that they've contempt along the
way i don't have a username for you i'm
sorry but i think that they'll dismiss
they'll cavalierly dismiss those that
have believed in ufos prior to the
evidence quote-unquote being revealed as
hey you should only follow the evidence
and so they'll be further cemented the
the rationalist let's say i don't know
what else to call them the neil degrasse
tysons i don't mean to pick on neil i'm
just
i'm using him as an idol for the as a
representation of
the
i don't know what to call it other than
the rationalist or the neil degrasse
tysons that they'll be further
entrenched in their view that hey well
now we just follow the evidence and it
doesn't matter that millions upon
millions of people had experiences with
these they had they had
great intuition sure but that needs to
be followed with a different with with
evidence and so on
i don't think there would be any
apology i don't think that there would
be any less disparagement i think that
the ufo community will get almost no
credit for being right about something
so
so obtuse in the sense that it's so
unlikely at least with our current
paradigm
how the heck could you be so likely how
the heck could you follow something and
be so correct for so long without
meaning that there's something true
about the intuition that you've followed
or the experiences that you've had and
perhaps that means the scientific
community needs to expand what they
consider to be evidence or at least
expand what they consider to be
evidence for avenues for further
exploration of a different kind of
evidence concrete evidence and so on it
comes to me even to what extent is what
too far
because then we go back to what you just
said about how einstein they were like
don't take it seriously and then it
turns out looking back
holy [ __ ] he was right
also when just discussing these topics
in an absence of physical evidence many
people most people most scientists would
agree that finding microbial life on
another on another planet would be one
of the
monumental discoveries of human
existence not just of the past decade or
century right
what if something much more profound is
occurring and then you wonder well
there's no physical evidence well how do
we
find the physical evidence without
discussing this topic and how do we
motivate people to find it
right right what just curious what would
a um
i know that you have to take off shortly
and i promise this is the last question
too that what what um
what would be the rebuttal to what you
just said there from professors
academics that seem to want to work
within which i'm not against but work
within a confined state of quote-unquote
provable um
i guess you could say
states or functions
what would their their rebuttal be to we
can't go too far out there type thing
if that makes sense
they would probably
suggest
something like i think it was
kent
who suggested that morality should be
what if quote unquote everyone did it
then it would still be okay
emmanuel so they can't yeah yeah i think
that they would say well what if
everyone in science did this extreme
speculation and discussing of unfounded
claims
then where would we be i think that
would be their claim i think that would
be their robot
right because that speaks to well then
my rebuttal is well not everyone's doing
that there's a certain temperament that
allows for that right
and channels like yours tunnels like
mine that we aren't
speaking to the i keep saying this but i
don't mean it in a political sense the
conservative center we're not speaking
to them we're speaking to an open
temperament a liberal with regard to
ideas a liberal mindset
right and the neil degrasse tyson types
would say that it's removed from
replicable data and that this is not
accessible to the public
and all of that's true
right so it
yeah but at the same time you have to
think about where are they deriding the
whole department of philosophy
almost all of the philosophical
department has zero data to support
their claims
zero data
right so and then yeah so they they
already have a certain mindset they
dislike and and i think that they just i
think that much of it is extremely
emotionally laden that they don't want
to be seen as these backward religious
hillbillies and that's that's at the
back of their mind at any given point
that they have a position on a social
hierarchy on in the in the
the midst of the savants that they
worship intellectually and they don't
want to be seen as some somewhere lower
on that academic hierarchy it's it's a
scholarly form of intellectual posturing
and to that to that and it i wow that
was very well said a scholarly form of
intellectual posturing so it would be
the idea like for example again i want
to be clear to both yourself sir and to
the audience that this is a purely
hypothetical example but say you know um
kurt brings on to his his great show uh
you know a professor that's in there say
let's just say hypothetically in their
80s in age and they've spent multiple
decades um
focusing on a particular set of theorems
and you know postulating axioms within
those theories and all that and all of a
sudden you have uh you know they're on
your show they're doing their thing
they're explaining their theory their
hypothesis and then here comes
mr kur jaimongal which please don't i'm
not trying to to degrade you relative to
this this hypothetical
no
no
no
not at all i'm a masochist
turn me on
here comes through you know uh 34 year
old kurt jay mungle sit you know poking
a legitimate hole in 80 odd-year-olds
professor so-and-so's hypothesis that
they've then
spent their whole life on and so to me
that again for
layman's terms of simplicity that speaks
to ego
very simply and and that's that that i
i think i i very slightly and maybe this
is incorrect of me but i sympathize to a
very slight extent because i i want to
put myself in their shoes of like
they've they've spent decades pursuing
particular paths but at the same time i
hate to be like this because it sounds
very i guess you could say narcissistic
or conceited of me but
if someone's proven wrong they're proven
wrong
you know regardless of how much time was
put into that that hypothesis if you
will so my my whole thing is again
speaking to that intellectual posturing
in the social hierarchy of things it's
like
to what extent are a handful of
academics just going nope
this is incorrect because they don't
want they feel threatened
if that makes sense
i know what you're saying yeah i agree
yeah it's not by the way yeah yeah yeah
continue continuing no i'm not looking
even for an answer just throwing
thoughts out at this point but
think about this this is something i
think about
fairly frequently let's say on a weekly
basis i think that if something turns
out to be true about this
ufo phenomenon
i don't think that the ufo
community will have any
credit that's deserved to them
i think that they'll still be
disparaged
and disesteemed
and sneered at by the likes of people
like neil degrasse tyson even though i'm
just
choosing his name i don't think that
he's as
contemalious as they make him seem the
reasoning goes like this let's imagine
that bigfoot turned out to be true let's
just take the case of bigfoot sure
people will forget about the tens of
thousands of people who had experience
who had experiences with bigfoot and
they'll just focus on oh there's
evidence for bigfoot now the community
won't get an apology it'll maybe get
some recognition vaguely as well there
look there are some historical people
who believed in this but it won't be
it won't be
it's some press conference where people
say yeah you all were right for so much
longer than we were and we were too
arrogant and supercilious to acknowledge
it and we apologize
it would be seen as a testament to yeah
well what you should do is still follow
the physical evidence because now what
we found was physical evidence of
bigfoot or ufos in the analogy rather
than
suggesting that what we should do as
scientists is re-examine what we
consider to be evidence because so many
millions and or at least hundreds of
thousands of people had this intuition
far before they were profoundly correct
right
rather than
than meaning that they're to be
repudiated for following some nebulous
form of quote-unquote evidence that we
should reevaluate what we consider to be
i'm losing my train of thought but
basically you don't see what's happening
like for example if i could if i could
very and i say this respectfully to mr
mr eric weinstein he tweeted out a few a
handful of months ago he said to the ufo
community i'm sorry he blatantly came
out and i respect that he came out and
said i'm sorry i was for you know quite
some time i was incorrect and i
dismissed this field as something of
nonsense or what have you he goes to all
of you i apologize you but you're
basically saying you don't see that
happening if anything comes out of the
uap field relative to the rest of
academia or a good chunk of academia
no and you can also think of it like
generally augurs don't get the credit so
for example nietzsche doesn't get credit
for predicting that there would be some
disastrous effects of following
a secular religion in the abandonment of
god and there were a few other people
who
said similar sentiments
so people who are historical who have
some
insight profound deep insight they don't
get much credit instead what you say
as an academic as well there are several
thousands of people who made predictions
some of them are going to be correct
you rarely get an admission of
following
an incorrect path from a scholar
that's what i see now eric weinstein is
an extreme exception to that but eric's
an exception in many ways right so
erickson
eric's an interesting person
right got you well with that said kurt i
want to thank you so so much man for
your time i want to thank you for coming
on and for even entertaining such um
such questions and and um exploring
hypotheses and these different ideas and
please i know that um
again i want to apologize if i phrased
any of the questions in a way that just
truly didn't make sense or anything i
apologize for not understanding them and
by the way i also want to say that the
people
that are that comprise the ufo community
they
tend to not care too much about
exoneration or punishment right they
just care about the quote-unquote truth
as far as i can tell the majority of
them and that's not like myself like i'm
much more of a selfish person so i'm
projecting plenty of how i would feel
dismayed and
and so on onto them but they're much
more selfless and kind-hearted than
than myself got you much as much of what
i said
maybe it doesn't matter to them
ah i got you and and with that said as
well would you be willing to let my
audience know although i'm sure that a
good chunk of my audience is familiar
with your work yourself your show but
where you could be found i'm sure
there's a handful that maybe aren't
sure
there's a channel called theories of
everything
you